we're here with shaq mamedyarov shaq you
had a topsy-turvy rapid section of the
tournament you beat magnus carlsen but
you had some problems here and there how
do you evaluate it okay after magnus of
course i play i blundered this in the
game against uh alireza
and also today's first game maxim it was
absolutely winning position in game and
i lose this position and of course in
last game is
absolutely winning position it looks
very easy winning position i think every
move is winning and it was
fantastic for him because i think
endgame is winning i mean it looks he
just goes with king and is winning but
obviously he played very fast it is
in game i don't know okay so it was only
one chance for him to play in the game
but somewhere i missed 38 and uh
tell us tell us about this rook dear
where did you miss it yeah i mean first
of all after
it was very good idea rookie rookie four
and take a look israel and there is
black is looks absolutely winning
position
and take take i think they remove i
played good uh
rook h5 is also like rookie five take
take of course here i can take his
knight also i can take
his looks bad but queen h5
i will show his bishop c7 knight e4 is
winning very easily and for this reason
i just play in one second this move 94
after bishop c7 and i have certainly
missed rook the 8th move but after rook
t8
i think is winning position because
normally it was my idea check
if play king g2
um
just
check king h2 i think same and i take
take and knight f2
this is
very good and this i think is winning
position but you're breaking each one
this looks very strange move but again i
i i after i miss f3 move i mean
f3 that's okay f3 after f3 is very good
chance for him for draw
and in the pawning it were you surprised
that he held on no but norma's looks he
hit his two pawns against three and king
just
come and eat all pawns but
what's fantastic is
but of course
but okay how i don't know
i don't know it does kind of defy the
loss of chess right outside past pawn
already still yeah
i mean it's queen c2 is
normally his draw position i mean very
good chance for him
for draw but queen h6 i think okay of
course i need to play this end game
because this looks you just
go with kings and i think too much here
about king d3 i think is yeah i think i
will take c4 king d3 is winning and the
king d3 is also it looks very good but
he's just come with king is very strange
king
just go again same
time
yeah
is win and right on time you take on p6
right
okay just this is big miss i mean today
i wonder in
first game and last game i just
plundered this winning positions to in
to winning position i just got half
points and it feels getting great
positions great stuff from the opening
great tactics what's missing what's
going on i don't know really i don't
know normally
uh when i
got these positions like winning
positions uh extra material i play well
but
today's
i mean i played today two games i really
uh two winning position i just
got half points and
okay i mean it's a
i don't know it's not a set note problem
it's just a
miss in
one moves and two moves well hopefully
you can recover for the blitz are you
excited for it change of pace i hope i
hope yeah because of course
after rapid okay
it's it will be not easy because in
rapid we have more times forcing but in
military we just need to push and set
not but okay i i mean i injured from
all games in this tournament and for
this reason i'm very happy with my chess
and results oh absolutely 18 more points
up for grabs shaq thank you for the
interview thank you that's it that
concludes the rapid portion of zagreb
that is just amazing a little unlucky
but shaq thanks for spending thank you
thomas good luck thank you thank you
give me back my microphone